the best image that I've come across for
the planetary situation is the birth
image a birth is an entirely natural
process that presents itself as some
kind of lifethreatening
Crisis I mean the mother is in agony
there is blood and there is this
appearance of Crisis and yet there's
nothing at all wrong here everything is
working toward its natural end it's
simply that two organisms which were
mutually bound together on one level of
the metaphor mother and child on the
other the human species and the planet
have after a long period of
coexistence and mutual reinforcement
come to The Parting of the ways and this
is part of the process of each growing
toward its completion but The Parting of
the ways is a
rening and a crisis point so uh it's
important that the birth go smoothly but
the aura of Crisis is uh not to be
construed as a license for despair or
the notion that we're encountering
anything unusual this is what it's like
when a species prepares to depart for
the Stars this is what it's like when a
species reaches a stage in its command
of language where it can become whatever
it seeks to be in its innermost
self-expression and uh my hope would be
that hundred years from now the planet
would be virtually empty of people the
people will have
gone into the human imagination to
world's richer and more fulfilling than
anything we can imagine and some will
have stayed behind to be the planetary
gardeners the tenders of the Legacy in
the same way that we have museums and
Botanical parks and they enrich us they
are our past they are our heritage this
planet is our heritage the bones of our
ancestors are buried in its swamps and
deserts our migrations took place across
its surface our dreams were molded out
of the marble and clay and metal that it
provided but eventually we came to the
end of that interuterine planetary
existence and broke through into the
full unfolding of our own becoming when
we underwent the kind of
metamorphosis that a caterpillar
undergoes to become a butterfly a true
spreading of our wings a true
unfolding of ourselves into the world of
the forms we would dream to be if we
could but dream ourselves into form and
uh it's what the planet yearns for and
cries out for it's done right by us it's
held it all together and provided it we
I bet when we get out into the universe
we will find intelligent life to be
extremely rare that doesn't mean it
won't exist but I think we will come to
have a real appreciation for the
metastable Dynamics of our planet that
it was able to keep the chemical
Machinery rolled pretty much
uninterrupted for a couple of billion
years till we could reach the place
where we could leave and take the
planetary Legacy with us so I really see
um you know the birth metaphor is the
metaphor of Hope it explains the aura of
Crisis it's touched with the poignancy
of
separation and parting and yet it must
be so it must be so for our sake and for
the sake of the whole of the organic
existence and it will be unimaginable
but these are the lines down which this
developmental Cree will uh
flow
[Music]